data exhaust is probably my least
favorite phrase in the Big Data world
because it sounds like something you're
trying to get rid of or something
noxious that comes out of the back of
your car but basically everything we're
doing now is being recorded and it never
is going to go away if you ever plan to
run for office if you're a teenager
remember everything you do every tweet
every facebook posting every picture you
put on instagram will be there forever
for journalists and politician to dig up
the whole idea of data exhaust is that
between our smartphones and our credit
cards and our easy passes and all the
other things that are collecting
information about us there's this three
dimensional portrait of each of us and
who we are and that is being analyzed
and sold to the highest bidder and it's
being used to understand people's
movements behavior patterns I'll give
you an interesting example of that
there's a company in Boston called
ginger I oh that has a smartphone app
that can predict two days before you get
depressed that you're going to get
depressed I was very dubious when I
first heard about this and I actually
spoke to the the gentleman who runs at
animal and he said I said first of all
how would a smartphone know I'm going to
get depressed before I do and who would
want it I mean why would somebody even
want to know that and he said well
actually first of all you have a regular
pattern of behavior basically each of us
has a radius of travel you know most of
us go to work at the same place we eated
similar restaurants we have similar
patterns of picking up our kids at
school so the first week the the
smartphone app just basically says this
is the radius to travel for Rick on a
day and two days before I start getting
depressed my radius of travel starts
shrinking the amount of time I spend at
home goes up the amount of emails and
tweets that I send goes down there's
this regular pattern of almost like
withdrawal and the reason that this is
actually useful and from a health
perspective and this is what ginger IO
has actually been focusing on is people
with diabetes have a very high
correlation with depression and when you
get depressed people stop taking their
medicine you know a higher percentage of
people than normal stop taking their
medicine if you have diabetes the the
consequences of not taking your medicine
quite severe organ failure blindness
it's quite dramatic so insurance
companies I want to make sure that you
stay on your medicine so basically you
sign up for this program if you're
diabetic and it basically says if it
looks like I'm going into one of these
depressive episodes a few days from now
let my doctor know and my kids know that
my spouse no my friend just to check in
with me to make sure that somebody you
know comes and notices that so it's
interesting this idea of this this that
our phones are starting to know us
better than we know ourselves or
starting to see patterns that we don't
detect on a day-to-day basis but the
phone sees this overall pattern and then
it looks for changes in that pattern